I had a question I mean I kind of want
to just bring it up like about the
recent Balenciaga stuff that's going on
and where there's evil where it's it's
demonstrated right in front of your eyes
and they don't even try to hide it does
the Quran mention anything like that
about watching out for evil specifically
and on not like strategies to like avoid
it but does it say anything about like
the strategies that these current people
are using to to push clear evil and
stuff that's clearly against uh the will
of God
um actually I'd say maybe surprisingly
to some people yes though there are
instances of that for example
um God would god mentioned Allah Quran
um there's a few different examples the
people that you know cause corruption in
the earth and then when you go to them
and say you're causing corruption they
say oh no we're just instilling peace
we're just instilling peace you know and
these people will come they'll be like
no we're just we're just fighting for
rights we're just fighting for basic
human rights well that's what they say
yeah it's crazy they're really hiding
something demonic under the Skies of
Human Rights but Islam will say well no
you're right rights who determines what
a right is you're just making it up and
then saying you're fighting for this
thing you made up all while hiding this
demonic thing Allah also mentions in the
Quran people who would be punished and
why are they punished because they put
themselves into bad predicaments you
know people like I'm guys like I'm gonna
go preach the message outside of a
nightclub it's like bro like you're
literally one step away from being
inside this demonic Hall and this is
where you want to go preach the message
like yeah they need it but is that the
circumstance you as a person should be
putting yourself in not necessarily I
would say same thing with you know maybe
going to some of these fashion
conventions or to some of these concerts
and I know you had a very specific
opinion on concert sunny and I love that
take
um those who don't know funny I believe
is against concerts because it's cringe
to go it's just jump Bob your head up
and down like a loser uh it's it's
really cringe honestly it's just a waste
of time
um and there are probably some I'm not
remembering currently but it's literally
all over the Quran but the best summary
to make as fast as possible is anything
that God tells us is good it's something
that's beneficial to us and will be good
for us and we should enjoy those things
anything that is Haram that is evil that
is wrong we should avoid it and as for
the measures we should take to avoid it
um the best best measure is prevention
complete prevention that's why people
will see Islam as strict but it's not
really strict in in all honesty it's
just we're so Loose as a society we
don't care what we do uh you can
literally the government will let you
drink till you kill yourself and it
doesn't really matter to them Islam will
say no anything that intoxicates you in
large amounts you cannot even have a
little bit of it so wow that's it's
really interesting you say that point
because I've kind of felt the same way
where they do a lot of this stuff with
the Trojan Horse so they'll say it's
just for acceptance It's just for mental
health and that's why they're giving
hormones to kids and it's oh God that's
the the excuses they use is a pretty
much Perfect Analogy of what you just
said and when you're young and even when
you're older you know you can be fooled
by causes and they and and because they
are do like perfect they come in a
trojan horse and so I think the way to
avoid that and I may just be repeating
what you just said mommy is just stay
true to God and then you don't you don't
put yourself on a path where you can
come into contact with a trojan horse at
all avoidance and you know it's like
what do I say nothing every every mother
says this nothing good happens after
nine o'clock out you know so stay in the
house that you know come home uh and and
that's kind of a simplistic way of
you know staying out of trouble
and staying away from those evil things
but the Balenciaga thing I think was
just so
so outrageously atrocious you couldn't
even make it up the level of detail they
went to to promote child pornography and
that's just like the most clear evil
that there is so it's so it's just crazy
to see that that's like one of the
biggest fashion companies that's what
their real motives are like I still
can't believe that that's that was a
real a real story that wasn't just a
scene in a in a in a weird movie yeah
but the thing is man this is we
shouldn't even be surprised about this
you know and we we shouldn't even look
to see uh or what what is said in
religions about these things I mean we
just need to use our clear judgment our
own eyes like we can see these things in
front of our eyes when I was younger I'm
not that old by the way let me say this
I appreciate that I appreciate it when I
was younger
I would go to these festivals
I would go to these things like EDC you
know what EDC is right yep bro I went to
EDC and let me tell you something
everyone lives on drugs either they're
on drugs or they're drinking and bro
that I was at this one Stadium where
it's like okay the music was nice at the
time but as will I jump in as we're
dancing everyone's like everyone looks
like NPC characters yeah they're Bots
yeah bro everyone's like I I swear to
God
I'm like what the hell
bro as this is happening there's random
things that are popping up on the stage
people aren't like they're not catching
on to it because they're so far gone
something else is controlling them at
that point in time whether they're
drinking or whether on a substance
something else is controlling them when
I was there on this stage clear as night
and day bro
do you know what bathroom is
you ever heard of Basil met no
Baphomet write that down do your
research on that that is
I think it's some kind of like demon or
something that these people worship
they were showing Baphomet just right on
the stage like this and I'm literally
like I stopped dancing
and I'm looking at this thing and I'm
just looking around to see if anyone
else is like catching this no one else
was catching it because again everyone's
like off somewhere else and from that
moment in time I was like whoa there's
something really messed up happening
here and I started doing my own research
turns out that that's not the first
thing and it keeps going deeper and
deeper and deeper and it's not just a
festival bro it's everywhere in the
world so it's like the Balenciaga stuff
so Nike has something at one point like
bro and no matter where you go like
these are signs that show us that we are
in the end of times or we are nearing
the end of times so it's again like we
don't we don't need something or someone
to tell us this it's just we just look
for ourselves and we can see it what is
the end of time
oh I was just going to wrap it up uh his
point with a lot of people ask these
questions like you see little now sex
giving say no lap dance is it really
that obvious isn't that too like you
guys really believe in Satan in this and
one of the tricks or one of the main
ideas or intentions of the devil is to
convince the world that he doesn't exist
yeah so in a way it really has to be
kind of out in plain sight
um that's a really good point
because that's that's what it's in an
episode we made about the metaverse that
they really need that type of consent
like if you look at demonic rituals and
how they kind of do what they do we
don't want to go too much you guys can
do your own research but when you do it
they need that consent from people they
can't do it behind people's backs wow
yeah that's really interesting because I
used to look at that stuff as kind of
just like uh whatever
like it's just them their culture not
their culture but I wouldn't look at it
as a as big of a deal and then I'd see
older people getting really mad at that
stuff and I kind of didn't understand
why they got so mad and then now when
you look deeper and you're like wow it's
it's it's not just like coincidence that
he's dancing on the devil like there's
true evil behind that stuff and it
really does change your whole
perspective on it all right make sure
you guys like subscribe and if you're
interested in learning how to dominate
social media and make money online I'm
having a crazy sale with my Online
Academy where I teach you all my
strategies how I've hit over a hundred
thousand Subs in four months how I've
generated five million dollars using
organic marketing so DM me bank if you
guys want to learn more about that
gone
[Music]
[Music]